es el adolescente que fue ante la puerta
equivocada y casi lo paga con su vida se
suponía que debía recoger a sus hermanos
en la casa de un amigo en la terraza 115
pero por error terminó en la calle 115 a
sólo una cuadra de distancia en esta
casa hogar de Andrew Lester de 84 años
se suponía que debía quedarse afuera
subían al auto y volvían a casa Eso era
lo que se suponía que pasaría y mientras
estaba allí parado sus hermanos no
salieron corriendo sino que recibió un
par de disparos en el cuerpo en lugar de
que un par de gemelos salieran y lo
abrazaran
Ralph fue alcanzado por dos balas una en
la cabeza y otra en el brazo Andrew
lestro dijo que disparó por miedo
inicialmente estuvo detenido durante 24
horas y luego fue liberado lo que
provocó protestas en toda la ciudad de
Kansas
este hermoso rostro negro es algo que
ahora estamos no por sus logros su
excelencia su belleza o simplemente por
ser negro sino porque le dispararon por
un perpetrador en un episodio de
violencia racial
los fiscales también hablan de un
componente racial en el tiroteo Mientras
tanto el presidente de Estados Unidos
Joe biden se pronunció en Twitter
ningún padre debería tener que
preocuparse de que le disparen a su hijo
después de tocar el timbre equivocado
tenemos que seguir luchando contra la
violencia armada y Ralph ya nos veremos
en la oficina oval una vez que te
sientas mejor el incidente podría poner
a prueba la llamada ley defiende tu
posición de Missouri que permite el uso
de fuerza letal Si una persona teme por
su vida Andrew Lester ha sido acusado de
asalto en primer grado y acción criminal
Armada ambos delitos graves si es
declarado culpable se enfrenta a cadena
per